this pride month nickelodeon in the form
of a drag queen
has an important message for your kids
they should
be true to themselves
baby blue p and white represent
transgender people
and black and brown represent the queer
and trans people of color
[Music]
we're all in this together so wave that
pride flag where
high go big be kind be you
doesn't it just fill you with pride
showing who you are on the inside
never have to hide yourself away there's
a place for you
[Music]
be true to you you need to be
true to you that absolutely
horrifying image but of course that's
preposterous
you should not be true to you you should
be true
to the truth which is not you it's
actually outside of you
when you and the truth are in
disagreement you should go with the
truth
but unfortunately the truth is basically
forbidden these days uncoved
a nationhood on human nature itself i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from old schooled
who asks a question he asks what's the
difference between a conspiracy theory
and the truth
the answer six to 12 months that's a
very good point absolutely true
if you want to remember things from the
past by the way
i would strongly recommend paint your
life if you want to give a truly
meaningful gift you've got to try
paintyourlife.com get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo
at a truly affordable price you choose
from a team of world-class artists you
work with them
until every detail is perfect it's a
very quick and easy process
you get a hand painted portrait in about
three weeks this makes the perfect
birthday
anniversary or wedding gift it's just
phenomenal i love these guys you send in
a photo or actually
multiple photos and they'll craft
something for you you'll work with them
every step of the way
you get i like the oil paintings you can
get other kinds of paintings it's just
beautiful i have one of these hanging in
my living room i would have two but i
gave one to my stepbrother as
a wedding gift and that one's gorgeous
too they're they're just
incred i love love this service makes
such a great gift great father's day
gift coming up
at paintyourlife.com there's no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed right now
as a limited time offer get 20 off your
painting 20 off and free shipping to get
this offer text
michael to 64 000. that's mich ael
to 64 000. text michael to 64 000 paint
your life celebrate the moments that
matter most terms apply available at
painterlife.com
terms that's michael text it to 64 000.
that image is from nickelodeon this
scary looking drag queen telling your
children
that they need to believe that little
boys or little girls and little girls or
little boys or whatever nonsense i mean
this
is horrifying i don't think this is
liberty contrary to some squishy
republicans i don't think these
this is one of the blessings of liberty
okay i don't think this is in the
american tradition
but if it is and count me out this is
something has gone wrong here if this is
what we are showing
children and it comes down to not even
this question of sex
it comes down to this question of truth
what is the truth what is our
relationship to the truth
what should we do when our views and
preferences and the truth
come into conflict who do we go with do
we go with ourselves
or do we go with the truth it's not just
the gender radicals
that are making demands on the truth
it's the scientists as well dr
fauci he's getting attacked all over now
because
he's been exposed as lying and deceiving
and just being flat-out wrong about a
lot of things
through the release of his emails and
through through other mechanisms
and he's punching back at his critics he
should be fired because
he in the beginning changed his mind
about masks
well okay so let's go back early on
with the masks and let's take a look at
that
at the time that we were saying we
shouldn't be wearing a mask there were
three factors that were going on
a there was a thought to be a shortage
of masks
b there was no evidence that masks
worked outside
of the context of a hospital i wear a
mask when i'm seeing patients
with respiratory disease that could be
transmissible like tuberculosis
a well-fitted n95
thirdly we were not aware of the extent
of asymptomatic spread
so we said you don't really need to wear
a mask as a scientist
as a health official when those data
change
when you get more information it's
essential
that you change your position because
you've got to be guided
by the science and the current data that
issue with mass
is people want to fire me or put me in
jail
for what i've done namely follow the
science
weak sauce buddy he he's a pretty slick
politician dr
fauci don't forget if you're in public
health you're half scientist half
politician the health is the science the
public
is the politics but this just does not
hold up at all he makes three claims
here we'll get to the first one last
because that that i think shows you
how silly his argument is the second
claim he makes
is that we we didn't know if masks would
work outside of hospitals
we look we thought that masks only work
inside buildings called hospitals but if
you took that same mask into a building
called a school
or a movie theater then it wouldn't work
because of the magical the magical walls
of the hospital what on earth either the
masks are going to work
at preventing transmission either
leaving the body or going into the body
or they're not the magical walls or the
magical name of the building as compared
to other buildings isn't going to change
that
he's trying to distract from the
question of do the masks work
to what buildings are we going to wear
them in but that's completely
unscientific that's illogical it doesn't
doesn't make any sense
then he says we didn't look the reason i
told all you stupid sheep not to wear
the masks
is because uh we did not know the extent
of asymptomatic spread okay so taking
look obviously there are studies saying
that the masks
work and there are a lot of studies that
say the masks don't work there's studies
that say that asymptomatic spread is a
gigantic problem
they're studies saying asymptomatic
spread really isn't much of a problem at
all
regardless of those studies though
you're telling me dr fauci
that you didn't know the novel
coronavirus that shut down the world you
didn't know the extent of asymptomatic
spread
so you aired on the side of recklessness
you didn't err on the side of caution
you didn't err on the side of let's
watch out in case asymptomatic spread is
a big problem
you air it on the side of oh don't worry
it's not a big deal you dumb sheep go
out and lick telephone poles
that's what you're telling me i don't i
don't think that's true
because at the same time you were saying
that you were saying 15 days to slow the
spread
stop your lives stop going to work i
think actually
it has much more to do with the first
argument he's trying to make to debunk
his critics but the first argument
actually proves that his critics were
completely right
because he says look the reason i
switched my opinion and the masks
you sheep is because i believe there was
a shortage of masks
whoa whoa whoa hold on so you're telling
me
that your professed opinion about the
masks
actually your opinion on the efficacy of
the masks
had nothing to do with what you thought
about the efficacy of the masks and it
had everything to do
with who you thought deserved the masks
right he's saying he's saying he's
actually said this almost verbatim
i wanted to preserve the masks for the
healthcare workers
not for you dumb peasant sheep right
he's almost verbatim not quite a few
words here i've taken some liberties
that's a political stance that's not
it's it's
not only is it not scientific it's
actually worse than that
he he was lying to you according to what
he's saying right now
he was lying to you about his opinion on
the efficacy of the masks
so that he would persuade you not to
wear the masks even though he thought
the masks were good
because he wanted to save those good
masks that he thought were
effective for his buddies in the
healthcare industry
that's much worse but regardless clearly
in
in his own line of thinking this the
science did not change
so much as the politics changed and when
he found out there were enough masks for
all you peasant sheep
then he told you they were effective and
that you
should wear them and actually you had to
wear them so he
comes out swinging against his critics
in a very impotent way
a way that might if you're just
listening to a fast talking politician
you're not paying very close attention
probably you wouldn't hear how
hollow his argument is and actually how
much he's actually undermining his own
argument
but then after he's striking out at his
critics
like me the i've noticed he also tries
to temper his voice now he tries to
sound a little less brooklyning but
you're not going to escape
dr farci that's your voice my friend
so not only does he strike back at the
opponents
then he goes on chelsea clinton's
podcast
to play the victim how do you think we
rebuild
trust and science and especially trust
in in vaccines and vaccinations
that is something that is not going to
happen easily chelsea i think that
we may have to find ways and and
that's a complicated issue as you all
know probably better than i do
it's a complicated issue of how you heal
the differences and and the hostility
i mean i've been the object myself of a
phenomenal amount of hostility merely
because i'm
promoting what really fundamental simple
public health principles that seems
astounding
that that would generate a considerable
degree of hostility
but it is it is but it is what did i do
i just lied to you
i just by my own admission lied to you
stupid peasant sheep and shut down the
whole world for no reason
why are people upset in me it's a it's
just a basic public health principle
first of all actually before we get into
dr fauci's argument here
i need to make the observation chelsea
clinton has a podcast that
i i am calling
for a complete and total shutdown of all
podcasts
until we figure out what the hell is
going on chelsea clinton does not need a
podcast
nobody is asking for that okay it's gone
too far
all right i say this is i have a podcast
obviously you're listening to that
podcast right now
it's too much guys it's there's too many
if chelsea clinton has one
we gotta that's it we gotta pull the
plug we gotta shut it down
okay back to dr fauci's argument
he's made this point elsewhere and
actually i go into great length
on on this point in my upcoming book
speeches controlling words controlling
mine's available pre-order yeah actually
the ding came in
even before i said it that's how used to
this we are getting
uh thank you by the way to everyone who
has pre-ordered that book we've got some
copies out there now some
sort of pre-pre-ordered review copies
that have gone out to various magazines
so people are starting to read it i look
forward to all of you reading it
we'll talk about this little aspect
right now though on the show
dr fauci said almost in these words i'm
paraphrasing only slightly
i have never had a political opinion
that i have made public in my life
i just focus on the science now what he
this is incoherent it just shows that he
he knows less about politics than he
does about
science significantly less actually
anything this man does in his
professional life is political
because he's in a public role and that's
what public means
moreover when he says
wear the masks that's a political
statement even further
when he says some people should get the
masks and other people should not get
the masks
that's a political statement but what he
is representing
is something the left has done for a
hundred years which is redefining
politics
out of politics saying that you cannot
have a legitimate disagreement it's just
dr
fauci it's just follow the science gotta
we gotta shut down the world well that's
just the science sorry we have to
we've got to put you out of business
well that's just the signs we got to
shut down your church but we got to keep
the marijuana shop open well look that's
just the science okay we've just got to
do that
it's not of course it's politics but
what they are saying and that you're
hearing this
louder and louder on issue after issue
not just here on covet but on
immigration
on abortion on transing the kids we're
being told it is not
acceptable for you to have a political
opinion if your opinion contradicts
difficulty
then unfortunately you've got to go with
dr fauci you've got to go with the
established science now what's good
is the republican lawmakers are fighting
back because dr fauci
he'll go on all these shows and he'll
play the victim to the world's smallest
violin and he'll yell and scream about
rand paul or whoever those of us in the
media who have criticized him
but he won't answer one really tough
question that republican lawmakers are
nailing him on
oh i love makes me feel so got my blood
pumping
to get ready to just absolutely hammer
dr fauci on this point you know what
else gets my blood pumping
echelon echelon's fitness app provides
you
thousands of live and on-demand classes
with great music from your favorite
artists with echelon you can work at any
time
day or night you just pick your class
track your workouts
and progress to reach your fitness goals
echelon certified fitness instructors
are supportive engaging
and fun there's a full range of
affordable workout equipment including
stationary bikes smart rowers
very sleek fitness screens or the auto
folding treadmill
all connected with the echelon
experience it's really really great
stuff
i have found you know it takes what you
go to the gym you do it takes like half
an hour to go to the gym and you get
changed
you do your workout and then you gotta
chill and you come back and just you
waste so much time you don't get a
really great workout
echelon makes it so much easier and one
membership covers a family of five right
now my listeners will get a special
podcast offer from echelon
for a limited time only start your
30-day risk-free trial offer with
echelon's ex3 bike
for just one dollar a special risk-free
offer for 30 days with echelon's ex3
bike
for only one dollar to start plus free
shipping only when you get that offer is
by going to echelonfit.com
e c h e l o n f i t dot com
echelon fit dot com slash knowles dr
fauci will go on all the shows and msnbc
and cnn and cry and wine about how
everyone's criticizing him he the most
powerful politician in the country who's
outlasted what how many presidents at
this point says ronald reagan the guy's
been in office
making major national policy over the
past two years but we're not allowed to
criticize him poor dr fauci boohoo
well top republicans on the house
oversight and judiciary committees
are demanding that he give them the
answer to a very specific question
not the masks not that whatever he said
on 16 minutes not that
more specific i want to read this letter
at some length but because there are
four parts to this letter and they're
really important here
okay because fauci has not given an
answer on this and i don't think he can
give an answer because i think the
answer will make him look really really
bad
here's the first part house republicans
remain concerned about the origins of
covid19 including
the increasing possibility that it
originated and subsequently leaked
from the wuhan institute of virology in
china at a 2012
conference entitled gain of function
research on hpa1 hsn1 viruses
you said quote what historically
investigators have done
is to actually create gain of function
by making mutations
passage adoption or other genetic
techniques such as reverse genetics so
i'm going to pause there
first part is because there's a big
debate did dr
fauci did the nih support gain of
function research gain of function
research it's very controversial
it's where you beef up naturally
occurring viruses to make them deadlier
to make them more transmissible why on
earth people would do this well i don't
to create bio weapons i guess i mean i
don't there's
very little function beyond that now
what dr faucia said when he's defended
this research is
no it's actually good because then we
learn how to protect against the insane
viruses that we're making you think
we'll just don't make it in the first
place okay
so the first thing they're establishing
in this letter is this is
what gain of function research is in
your own words
this is what it is this is how you make
it okay
they go on in 2014 you through the
national institutes of health awarded
eco-health alliance a grant
entitled understanding the risk of
background of virus emergence this grant
allowed eco-health
to quote test predictions of coronavirus
transmission
using reverse genetics
stop there you're denying dr fauci that
you have anything to do with funding
this kind of research and the gain of
function and the background viruses okay
here's your definition of what gain of
function is
here is a grant that you guys awarded
for this kind of
research third part funds from this
grant were subsequently awarded
to the wuhun institute of virology using
your own definition
it appears that the nih funded gain of
function research
at the wuhan institute of virology okay
you see very methodical here dr fauci is
outright we didn't
not only did we not fund this kind of
research we certainly didn't fund this
kind of research at the wuhan institute
of virology
the kind of research that almost
certainly is the cause of shutting down
the entire world and curtailing a lot of
our political rights and upending
global economies and societies for the
past year and a half
the house republicans are proving no you
did that according to your own
definitions
you did that and then finally on may 11
2021
while testifying under oath you stated
the nih has not ever and does not now
fund gain of function
research in the wuhan institute of
virology
this appears to contradict your 2012
statement regarding gain of function
research and the
institute of virology nailed it got him
that's it you know we focus on the
things he's said in public
and the masks and the things that really
impact us day in and day out okay and
then he tries to weasel his way out of
it
weasel your way out of that buddy i'm so
glad
that the the house republicans have put
this out there he's not going to
answer it and this is going to get
buried in the media don't let them bury
it remember it save this clip
save this video they got him on it
and there need to be consequences for
that
is it lock him up lock him up throw him
in jail i don't know i don't i don't
know if he committed a crime
i suspect he actually didn't commit a
crime i suspect we just have stupid
rules in this country and stupid
bureaucrats running our world in a way
that
shuts shuts down the whole thing i mean
i think it was uh
it was it was some very famous
conservative who said that modernity is
uh bureaucracy tempered by incompetence
that's that's what what dr fauci is
giving us
but surely there needs to be a
professional consequence for this surely
the man
must be fired who
is defending the truth
who is the science who is defending the
truth certainly not
our schools the very least schools
should be defending truth right
but no the kind of incompetence that
we're seeing from dr
fauci and we're seeing from the broad
public health establishment
that not only is terrible at its job
but actually doesn't even know what its
job is can he can't even make sense of
the distinction between science and
politics
well starting in schools there is an
elite middle school in new york city
right now
it's the lab middle school very very
well known to new yorkers
this middle school is getting rid of
leveled math courses
you remember this when you were in
school certainly high school
middle school even elementary school
some kids are just a little smarter than
other kids
okay that's just a fac it's a natural
fact
and you can either encourage people's
strengths and talents
or you can discourage people's strengths
and talents
and for the history of education we have
encouraged people's
strengths right if you're if you're good
at math you're going to be in the
enrichment math class
if you're good at some language maybe
you'll be in the
advanced language class you go to
history you'll be in the advanced
placement history class but this creates
a real problem for our
egalitarian democracy of equity
and whatever slogan they have today
because that means that the slower kids
are are not going to be in that class
it's going to create a sort of hierarchy
it's going to create
gradations okay and oh heaven for fend
if the if members of a certain group
are in one class and members of another
group are in another especially if this
involves
sex and most especially if this involves
race
if all those asian kids are in the math
class
oh my gosh that's that's wrong it's
bigoted
because what hap what happens if there
are disproportionately more white and
asian kids in the advanced math class
and what happens if they were
disproportionately less say black or
latino or any other kind of kid in those
classes well now this is an issue of
white supremacy
and including the asians somehow the
asians are white i guess and this is a
matter of
bigotry and we've just got to get rid of
the classes
they've they haven't given an
explanation for why they're doing it but
but they're doing it at this school and
you're seeing this happen more and more
when i was in school we had
valedictorians when i was in school we
had
class presidents i don't know when i was
in school we had these sorts of
distinctions between people
and then i started to notice after i
graduated they started to get rid of
these things
at many many high schools many in
other schools colleges middle schools no
longer
are there valedictorians at many schools
because if someone's a valedictorian
then a lot of people are not the
valedictorian and that's
that's going to make people feel bad and
it's probably unjust you know
if someone's the class president some
said someone else isn't and that's not
fair
right what we're seeing is a reminiscent
of a story by kurt vonnegut called
harrison bergeron
which it's actually been quite a while
since i've read it the premise of the
story is in this
dystopic future you've you've got
a world in which everybody needs to be
brought down
to the lowest common denominator it's
not that some people do really well and
so we're going to try to bring people up
and encourage other people to have
either that same talent or other talents
and encourage diversity
right no everybody has to be handicapped
everybody has to be crippled everybody
has to be brought
down to the lowest possible level and
that way we will have
equality this is a distinction
between modern liberalism and classical
conservatism call it
okay in the classical conservative view
of things
there is excellence and some people are
going to have greater excellence than
others
and some people are going to have
greater talent at some things than other
things
you know i i know i look like a hulking
football player but actually that isn't
where i am most excellent but i have
other talents and so do you and so does
everybody and that's those are the sorts
of things we encourage there is
virtue there is order some people
are going to be picked first for the
baseball team some people are going to
be picked last for the baseball team
some people are going to do very well on
their s.a.t some people are not going to
do very well in their sat
and it's not because of injustice
exactly it's not because of the systemic
problem it's just because you know some
people are a little smarter
some people are a little taller some
people have a little bit more muscle
we're not all exactly the same
but but modern liberalism is leveling
degrading egalitarian equity is the name
of the game
not even just on sports or something not
even just on
in terms of the math classes not even
just within the sexes
but actually men and women we are we are
told with this completely straight face
by these leveling equity obsessed
modern libs men and women have to be
exactly the same
when a man puts on a dress and runs a
track race
there is nothing unusual about that
and one should not find anything wrong
with that and because the girls have
just the same chance because men and
women are exactly the same oh the man
wins every single time well that's
he's a woman so there's nothing nothing
surprising here
it's so degrading and they do it in the
name of justice but of course it results
in a great injustice
now ben will be talking about our our
beautiful wonderful genius experts today
uh whom he refers to as self-serving
idiots fahren i think he's actually
going a little light on them but yes
that's true check out ben's show
you can now find all the conservative
content that you love wherever you are
all on the daily wire app even if you're
not a daily wire subscriber
you will be the first to know what's
trending with mobile notifications for
the latest news
and all of your favorite content all of
your favorite
your single favorite show out there i'm
not talking about the chelsea clinton
show
okay i'm talking about another show
download the daily wire app and stay up
to speed with the freshest conservative
voices around
no matter where you are we'll be right
back with a lot more
radical egalitarianism is the name of
the game these days
equity is the term but it's not equity
to bring everybody up
it's equity to bring everybody down it's
an equity and egalitarianism that does
not recognize
certain distinct doesn't even recognize
the distinction between nations
it doesn't even recognize that the
government of the united states
has a special duty to its own citizens
no
because that's that's not equal it's not
egalitarian
what about the poor nicaraguans well i
don't know i mean we can give them
charity we can
be nice to nicaragua but the new view is
no the
the government of the united states has
just as much of a responsibility
to foreigners as it does to its own
citizens it erases even the idea of a
nation
joe biden just showed this today he
showed this because
he's meeting with european leaders next
week and he is already telling us
that he is going to drop u.s protective
tariffs on steel
and aluminum now this is an issue that
has divided the right
because for the really only the past 20
or so years not even
there's there's been this free trade
absolutism there's this idea that
tariffs never work tariffs are
are anti-conservative and this is just
historically ridiculous the republican
party was founded on tariffs okay
abraham lincoln said give me a tariff
i'll give you the greatest nation on
earth
the republican party was always the
protective party
the t the pro-tariff party the
conservative movement was pro-tariff
until the latter part of the 20th
century
and there are plenty of good reasons to
get rid of some tariffs but they're
instrumental reasons there is no
no universe in which tariffs are
anti-conservative you know just as a
as a general principle as an eternal
truth that that has
never been the case but here's some more
evidence of it
who are the presidents in recent memory
most well-known for instituting steel
tariffs
trump and reagan trump and reagan
they're the two they're the two pres
the two most conservative presidents
that we've had in a hundred years at
least
are the two presidents who instituted
the steel tariffs and now joe biden
getting rid of it
why is he getting rid of it well to
answer that question you'd ask
why did we have the steel tariffs in the
first place why do we use tariffs at all
we use tariffs because the idea of
absolute
free trade just doesn't exist i loved
this question that trump asked
when some of the squishy types were
yelling at him for for even suggesting
the use of tariffs
he said if your your argument is that
tariffs don't work
okay if tariffs don't work why does
every other country use them
if tariffs they actually hurt your own
country if tariffs
are so self-destructive they never
achieve anything how come every other
country on earth has them except for us
and actually we have them too but you're
just sort of pretending that we don't
because they obviously do work to
achieve certain objectives
they work as a matter of leverage to get
other countries to lower their tariffs
which is better for our economy
and they work to protect our industries
certain american workers who can be
protected by those sorts of tariffs
in this specific case of steel tariffs
why are we instituting it here
because china is cheating china is
illegally
subsidizing its steel and aluminum
industries china's share of global crude
steel production
increased in the year 2020 from 53.3
to 56.6 percent now we don't really
import steel from china
but the problem is that china's
overproduction of steel in violation of
treaties
depresses the price of steel on the
global market and it hurts our steel
manufacturers okay and there are other
issues with this as well
but but joe biden's getting rid of these
tariffs the allegedly you know the
least conservative thing in the world
well you know joe biden doesn't seem to
agree with that assessment
that so many conservatives have of
tariffs so he's getting rid of the
tariffs
because well it's not fair it's not fair
to these other countries
look yeah maybe it's better for us maybe
it's better for our industry maybe it's
better for our workers but you know it's
not that's not nice to china
and joe biden man that guy's been
cheering on china's rise for decades at
this point explicitly
makes us rethink certain things not just
on economic matters not just on trade
deals for instance or tariffs
but on on immigration
the department of homeland security was
created by bush ii
after 9 11 brought together a number of
different departments
and what dhs is focused on right now
what it's supposed to be focused on
is keeping foreigners who cross into
this country illegally
out of the country okay that's one of
the one of the main focuses
if not the main focus of the department
of homeland security
but the new radical secretary of
homeland security
alejandro mayorkas says that actually
the foremost priority of dhs is the
dignity
of the illegal aliens i grew up with a
very strong sense of
my identity as a refugee and what it
means to be displaced fundamentally in
one's life
and so i asked when we were in fact
confronting difficult policy questions
the question of identity what as we
struggle to reach an answer
what would the answer say about who we
are and who we want to be
and i think that there are two
foundational or guiding principles
uh that really drive the answer
one is the concept or actually
the element of dignity and the other
is the rule of law those are
two foundational guideposts
as i seek to lead an agency
as we as servants of the law
seek to bring justice in whatever
we do and here in the department of
homeland security i think
um that must guide everything that we do
in that word salad is this guy ever
going to give a direct answer he does
you just got to read between the lines
he says
the the things that guide us our dignity
dignity and the rule of law
now he's trying to put these things
against one another because he's not
talking about the dignity
of the american people he's not talking
about the dignity of the american
immigration system he's not talking
about the dignity of our borders
he's talking about the dignity of
criminals
foreigners who enter our country
illegally and flout our laws it's the
first thing they do here
the the that's not a dignified act but
he's saying that has dignity i thought
about my identity
as a refugee i want you to think about
your identity as an american
and i want you to think about your
identity as the
director of homeland security and i want
you to think about
your identity as the enforcer
of the rule of law when he says it's
about dignity and the rule of law what
he's saying is
it's about opening the floodgates
ignoring the rule of law
and only prioritizing the illegal alien
and it comes from i get where it comes
from
it comes from this radical egalitarian
idea we
i i feel it myself to some degree
right i can at least sympathize with
this we live in a very rich
country we live in a country at least
for now that has relative
political freedom and a generally
pleasant political tradition
and nice communities and lots of stuff
and lots of opportunity
and other people don't live in those
countries and that's unfair i guess
isn't that's unfortunate at least
and so if we recognize the dignity and
the equity then we've got to let them in
we have to we have to even if that will
substantially weaken
our own country radical egalitarianism
this is true overseas too not just to
our neighbors in the south
even across the pond in the motherland
there are some woke students at oxford
university right now
who have voted to remove a portrait of
queen elizabeth ii
from a common room at maudeland college
very famous place
at oxford because this represents the
uk's quote
colonial history
queen elizabeth one of the most
dignified people
on planet earth this woman has given her
life to her country
she has served and served and served
she may be one of the most beloved
people on earth but you see
the queen it's not very egalitarian
because the if there is such a thing as
a queen it's a it's a poke in the eye
it's just it is the logical conclusion
of the
of the different math classes it's a
recognition that different people are in
different positions in life
and you're every everybody is not going
to be in exactly the same position
you can try by the way the only way you
can try is just by bringing everybody
down lower and lower and lower which is
what they're trying to do but you're
still not going to get it
some people are still going to be better
at math some people are still going to
be born with certain privileges we're
all born with certain privileges some
people are still going to be born with
certain disadvantages
to to some degree you must accept your
lot in life
you must reconcile you but we can't do
that even
at the question of nature we have now
cartoons and
and kids networks telling kids you don't
have to accept anything about your lot
in life including your biology
including nature you can break that too
you see here so very often in this
country
we try to posit liberty you know
emancipation and equality as opposites
the way that the political debate has
worked for a long time in this country
is that the right stands for liberty
and the left stands for equality and
these two things are in conflict with
one another but actually
they both work together quite well the
the goal here for the radicals for the
liberals you know even the liberals on
the right
is this perfect utopian equality
and the way that we're going to get that
equality is by emancipating liberating
people from their conditions that's why
you hear
this talk of liberation so much on the
radical left
even among communists right even among
actual
marxists that is
the the ultimate liberation that comes
at the end of
end of the line here but
reality reasserts itself
reality comes back in the end there's a
poll speaking of our friends across the
pond
poll the majority of britons support a
ban
on migrants seeking asylum
so we're talking about even people
seeking asylum you know safety plea this
is what
we're told now is all immigration is
people fleeing political persecution but
they're not usually economic migrants
but the majority of people in britain
support a ban on migrants seeking asylum
a ban an outright ban according to this
poll
do you think that the government of
great britain is going to
follow that no but hold on a second here
i thought
that we had to defend democracy i
thought we had to channel the will of
the people
you know all this talk about our
democracy
which angelo cotavillo points out is
actually just
the elites referring to their oligarchy
our democracy means their oligarchy
what about our democracy well our
democracy
in great britain says ban the migrants
they won't do that the radicals don't
particularly care for democracy
there's another poll here in the united
states majority of voters in the united
states support abortion restrictions
after
15 weeks this is a poll released by the
susan b anthony list
found the majority of likely voters
support these sorts of restrictions
do you think that the supreme court will
recognize our democracy
no they're going to actually insist on a
fictional constitutional right to
abortion they made up in between the
penumbras and the emanations
do you think even our legislators
frankly do you think even our republican
legislators many of them are going to
care about our democracy here
on the abortion restrictions i don't i
don't think they care about our
democracy at all
i think the left is actually quite
antithetical to our democracy there's
another poll you know how much i love
polls
i don't really buy polls but when they
support my opinions i'll cite them
there's a poll that shows
just out now shows that liberals are
more likely to unfriend
people over politics on social media and
in real life
quote democrats are twice as likely
as republicans to report having ended a
friendship
over a political disagreement 20 percent
of democrats said they've ended a
friendship over a political disagreement
compared to 10
of republicans uh this is a survey from
the american survey center
it also found quote political liberals
are far more likely than conservatives
are
to say that they are no longer friends
with someone due to
political differences 28 percent versus
10 respectively
and then when you focus just on women
the number gets even more insane
33 of liberal women have quote
stopped being friends with someone
because of their politics what about our
democracy what about hearing all voices
what about inclusion and diversity of
course they don't believe in any of
these sorts of things
they have contempt for our democracy the
same people who talk about our democracy
are the ones who refer to our countrymen
as bitter clingers who cling to their
guns in religion and the only reason
they question
insane trade deals is because they have
resentment toward immigrants or
something and they're bitter and
and filled with grievance the same
people who clamor on about our democracy
are the ones who call their countrymen
deplorable and irredeemable
they don't believe in this sort of thing
at all this radical egalitarianism
has nothing to do with the care for the
their actual countrymen actually they're
dragging their countrymen kicking and
screaming
into this dystopia
in our democracy you're not really
allowed to question the government
anymore are you
are you on social media if you
raise a question about the 2020 election
if you point out that there were a whole
lot of
irregularities is that the term we're
allowed to use there were a lot of
irregularities there
you could be banned you could look you
could be investigated for goodness sakes
there was a game at fenway at the red
sox ballpark
and someone just unfurled there's lots
of flags and banners and signs
someone unfurls a little flag out there
out in left field
says trump won trump won okay
now this is an unobjectionable statement
first of all
certainly he won in 2016. no i guess
you're not actually i'm sorry
i've i've been told by hillary clinton
and by the entire leftist establishment
that all the media and every i've
actually been told trump lost that
election and he stole it remember
trump's not a legitimate president
according to them so i guess you're
allowed to question that election but
you're not allowed to question this
election
which was far more vulnerable to fraud
that fan was ejected from the game
you're not allowed to say that
you're not allowed to question the
government in our democracy
and and by the way the the people who
are the enforcers of this are not always
from the government
they're from the broad blob as well but
you're not allowed to question it so
much for democracy
our democracy types are
actually not only disdainful of their
fellow countrymen
they're actually willing to attack basic
elements
of our actual constitutional democracy
there was an la times columnist
virginia heffernan who just
made a pretty radical suggestion about
people who exercise their second
amendment rights very basic civil rights
in this country
she said real estate listings should
include the prevalence of gun ownership
in a 50-mile radius
and a number of annual mass shootings in
the region time to change what a bad
neighborhood is
and introduce a meaningful tax on guns
and gun violence no one should say this
is a great place to raise kids about
neighborhoods where even one person has
an assault rifle
we don't need to rehash the obvious
points that what she thinks an assault
rifle is is not actually an assault
rifle
yada yada you get it i want to focus on
the call here she's asking
that the addresses of gun owners be
published
making them targets making them targets
for burglary making them targets for
ostracism making them targets for
violence for for exercising a very basic
right
the journal news actually where i where
i grew up in new york did this some some
years ago
they published lists of of the addresses
where
gun owners live the places that these
gun owners are
i don't even just want to focus on that
i want to focus on the divergence
between what she's suggesting in reality
she's saying
we need to redefine what a bad
neighborhood is and now we're going to
we're going to define a bad neighborhood
as places where people have
ar-15s
the problem with that is those aren't
bad neighborhoods
people have ar-15s in good neighborhoods
ar15s are just not used in very many
crimes
very very few this is a well trodden out
statistic it's almost become tedious
more people are killed each year with
bats and hammers and clubs and fists
than they are with rifles of any kind
including the dred ar-15 now
guns are involved in some crimes much
more often pistols that's much more
often
not not in the trump counties okay it's
more often in chicago
in detroit and washington dc and new
york
and los angeles not places that are
voting for donald trump not places
that are great defenders of their second
amendment rights not places that are
buying the ar-15s
actually this woman has undermined her
own argument here because she's saying
that all these places you know out in
the country where people have ar-15s
those are the bad neighborhoods they're
not we know they're not
you know they're nice neighborhoods
actually people like to go there they
have high real estate prices okay
and they're not even you know they're
some play you know if you go to a city
for instance there will be high real
estate
prices depending on what neighborhood
you're in but there's so much economic
opportunity and you're making a lot of
money
and there's lots of social services and
high taxes and but we're talking about
places that are just sort of nice you
know that people actually would like to
go to
it's not you can't just redefine reality
that way the left loves redefining
reality that's
sort of the central premise of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds which is
available you can get a signed first
edition copy
at premiere collectibles books coming
out in two weeks at which point i will
not be able to say it's
available for pre-order it will just be
available for order speaking of bad
neighborhoods kamala harris just made
what i think is her best
argument for
these radical immigration policies i
don't think it's a good argument but i
think it's her best argument so i want
to take it seriously
it's not about quid pro quo it's simply
about understanding
if if nothing else that the return on
our investment
is the same return on your investment
that if you have a neighbor
on your block where you grew up was
having a hard time
it's in the best interest not only of
your neighbor but yourself to my to help
them out
right and um that's how we think about
this work
what is the united states interest in
this we're prepared to show up
and do it in a way that is motivated
by the best interest of diplomacy and
democracy
and goodwill and so this is a very
different view of foreign policy than
donald trump's donald trump's was
we're going to do things that benefit
america this was common sense until very
recently
our foreign policy is to benefit our
country be in the national interest
kamala's view is we need to have a
foreign policy that promotes global
democracy
sort of liberal imperialism
but why why i understand the argument if
she says
it's in our interest for guatemala to be
a better country
it's in our interest for guatemala to be
more flourishing to have a better
economy
okay i get that why is it in our
interest for guatemala to be more
democratic
how is that in our interest
there are plenty of democracies that
collapse and fall and fail
and then all those migrants are going to
keep coming over
why democracy why democracy
even at the same time that kamala and
her democrat friends
undermine our democracy right democracy
is full of deplorables and irredeemables
and bigger bitter cleaners
what the left has done is try to remove
those democratic elements and give all
the power to the doctor vouchers of the
world
but so we're undermining democracy at
home but we're promoting democracy
abroad why
it's totally incoherent
because what they mean by our democracy
is not our democracy when
conservatives participate in our
democracy it is considered illegitimate
give you
an example very timely for during our
pride month
we'll begin we'll end where we began
with drag queens
laverne cox who is a man who wears a
dress just gave an interview to variety
talking about how important it is that
we trans all the kids he said quote
what they're trying to do what they the
conservatives are trying to do is to
dehumanize these children
which is so heartbreaking it's really
heartbreaking when you see the way
they're talking the fervor with which
they're going after these kids in the
face of that
we we insist on the humanity of everyone
insist on the humanity of trans people
and particularly
trans children of course it's the
opposite the transgenderists are the
ones trying to dehumanize children
they're trying to get the children to
deny their human nature
and to pretend that they are women when
they're
men and men when they're women vice
versa they are they are
quite literally quite specifically
dehumanizing the kids
cox goes on a few years ago it was all
about the bathrooms right there were a
slew of bills all over the country
attacking trans people in the background
bathroom now pause there who are the
aggressors
in this culture war we had a men's room
in our ladies room then the left got
upset with that and said no
let men have to be able to use the
ladies room and republicans said no they
can't and now that's called the
aggression
and he says it was about trying to make
trans people not exist let me
not put too fine a point on it trans
people do not exist
it's not a thing do you know who does
exist men who
have a psychological condition where
they think that they're women those guys
exist
i suppose deserve our sympathy and
certainly deserve our compassion our
help
you know who does exist uh men who very
much want to be women because they have
some sexual preference that way
that certainly exists but trans people
the idea of a man who then becomes a
woman
that does not exist that is a fake thing
and if you
if you deny that that exists as
virtually everyone for all of human
history everywhere it does
if you make this obvious point if you
just hold to the truth
right you just say this basic truth
that's deemed illegitimate and out of
our
our democracy beyond the limits of our
democracy so much for our democracy i'm
michael nolan's michael knowles shall
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show our journalism
experts blew it yet again on a major
story targeting president trump
dr anthony fauci declares that attacks
on him are attacks on science
and even the white house is now
disappointed in kamala harris that's
today on the bench bureau shall give it
a listen